well oops and welcome to this video good
night mr. Thomas the opponent so let's
see greenford reverse it's a nice
opening but it can transpose to all
kinds of things Catalans yeah no way
transpose to them to the Queens gambit
arash and III is one one decent line
yeah people know their openings that
looks very strange but it is possible
quindi 595 I don't even know what what
they play then I know that this is what
I play with it some it's not that bad
for black check yeah that was actually
analyzed in the opening repertoire the
GM repertoire tirage defense and from
quality chest and they analyze this
claiming that black can draw this end
game that might be true okay it's no end
game but now I can draw this queenless
game but yeah it's not it's not big fun
and in any case so before white still
has a slight slight pressure so when I
saw this line I thought okay well they
might say it's a draw but black still
has to show me how how he does it so
let's let's see here night to e4
up to 26 it's not bad what's the idea of
95
not quite clear what is movies 96 is
quite a bit of a problem
hmm yeah I don't know I don't know what
you should play it's not easy to same 96
and 97 oh that's them that's the problem
someone might be seven or anything
better even I probably not to get to
take Matt you might move the 1994 or
something for come to play yep so what
now don't even know instead of threat I
can also play Quincy 3m just trying to
trade no particular reason not to do
that right let's do that
how can you not treat Quincy pepper so
here I am I thought rook III just keep
keep the a porn and a for next
Jim a for 293 I don't know maybe that's
not push it push it too quickly this is
also not bad
okay I wonder 95-96 might be an idea you
found my d6 that's a number of quite
good options so let's do this
now thinking wiki edits it's a bit bit
cool but should should do with the job
check check no no no don't tell me that
10 didn't see that movie I backward
moves backward moose are often tricky to
find ah what a joke no no no no I don't
give you a draw here let's just first
check this
Bishop c6 a son is doing doing the trick
here I guess
Jim you see even quicker them kini seven
though I'm picking that up so let's go
him it's probably still a draw
up to e3 95 is not drawing I think maybe
it is but ok I didn't have any good
alternative anyway check
King here that goes right over there so
King here King is much more active him
so here for night c 8 I might have
enough time to play but let's have a
look at you I have something else
entirely don't get to trip the night
that's not possible time morning let's
do that i also have noticed each day to
g6 year i wonder if that is an idea it
sound kini for that's really very
dangerous counterplay put it I'm
promoting right here when he will take
be 5 9 p-5 I'm not sure if that's
winning check him
and now I'm coming with 9c aid yes he
doesn't have the counter play now with
the king
check check check check mate chair gym
made my life much more difficult than
necessary yet by far more difficult
after one be seven the game is just
really over but I screwed that up really
badly I have a technical claim very bad
should go maybe age 3 95 or something
like that 95 is a good idea yeah that
that's just nonsense it's nonsense that
move i was thinking i get i get i traded
and we'll just win but it's just bad
just this is much better he has to go
back somewhere and then i'm playing this
yeah with the gain of tempo let's say
and this is very easy actually i also
have 96 sometimes and the bishop
everyone yeah that's a very easy win but
that just just touches bad am not be
seven in china I just don't look Bishop
d7 of course if it is not for that move
it would be okay but it works it just
works yeah and here I have nothing so I
wonder when it starts to get tricky here
here yeah 95 this is a an interesting
moment I wasn't sure if this is a draw
or not I think it is probably but check
look at this I was thinking my active
King might be who are something like
here but this is not leading anywhere
yeah that's a draw yeah that that was
the way to join and here no I think this
is also interesting might also draw
check here I'm absolutely not sure
anymore lacking d3 is even better okay
with it it is tricky now and here wyd
wins this this night c8 txtx here f4
here and night Kevin does win yet I
wasn't totally sure I really wasn't
completely sure if that does win like
this this this ah this is the point yeah
I really I wasn't totally sure here I'm
always covering with this I didn't see
not deform that I can prevent sorry that
I can prevent king of three this is of
course then very easy f king of three is
not coming check Jeremy ta can draw with
92 and this again lose this yeah I
wasn't sure if this is one end game is
winning or not okay damn have to have to
fight have to continue even after
screwing up the end game in the first
place they will sometimes be chances
later okay well thanks for watching